♪ ♪
>> Dana: HELLO EVERYONE, I AM
DANA PERINO, 5:00 IN
NEW YORK CITY, THIS IS
"THE FIVE" ."
THE BATTLE FOR 2020 GETTING UP
NOW THAT JOE BIDEN HAS
OFFICIALLY ENTERED THE RACE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP GOING ON THE
ATTACK AGAINST THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT AND DEMOCRATIC
FRONT RUNNER.
>> HE IS NOT THE BRIGHTEST LIGHT
BULB IN THE GROUP, HE IS NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH
PRESIDENT GEE, THAT'S A
DIFFERENT LEVEL OF ENERGY AND
FRANKLY, INTELLIGENCE.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE IT, I AM A
YOUNG, VIBRANT MAN.
I LOOK AT JOE, I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT HIM.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> Dana: BIDEN RETURNING FIRE
TODAY ON "THE VIEW."
>> THE BEST WAY TO JUDGE ME IS
WATCH, C.
I HAVE THE ENERGY AND THE
CAPACITY.
THIS IS SHOW ME BUSINESS.
>> SO YOU AREN'T SLEEPY JOE?
>> THAT IS THE FIRST TIME I'VE
EVER BEEN REFERENCED THAT WAY BY
ANYONE ELSE.
>> Dana: HE WAS ALSO ASKED
ABOUT CONTROVERSIES THAT COULD
HURT HIM IN THE PRIMARIES
INCLUDING ALLEGATIONS OF
VIOLATING PERSONAL SPACE AND HIS
TREATMENT OF ANITA HILL.
>> ARE YOU PREPARED TO APOLOGIZE
TO THOSE WOMEN?
>> I AM REALLY SORRY IF WHAT I
DID, IF, IN FACT, THEY TOOK IT A
DIFFERENT WAY.
SORRY I INVADED YOUR SPACE, I AM
SORRY THIS HAPPENED.
>> YOU REACHED OUT TO ANITA HILL
AND EXPRESSED SOME REGRET TO HER
ABOUT THE WAY YOU BEHAVED BACK
IN 1991.
>> IN TERMS OF -- IF YOU GO BACK
AND LOOK AT WHAT I SAID AND
DIDN'T SAY, I DON'T THINK I
TREATED HER BADLY.
SPEAK TO THE PRESENT IS NOT
WAITING
WASTING ANY TIME, HE IS JUST GOI
WASTING ANY TIME, HE IS JUST GOG
TO GO FOR IT RIGHT AWAY.
>> Jesse: THE SLEEPY THING
DEFINITELY STICKS, I DIDN'T
REALIZE HOW SLEEPY HE WAS UNTIL
HE ANSWERED QUESTIONS ABOUT HIM
BEING SLEEPY.
THERE IS GOING TO BE AN ISSUE
FOR JOE AND I DON'T THINK HE
WILL HAVE THE TEMPERAMENT OR THE
PALLET TO HANDLE IT.
HE'S NOT USED TO BEING THE FRONT
RUNNER OR USED TO BEING ATTACKED
FROM THE LEFT AND HE'S NOT USED
TO TOUGH QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEDIA.
HE IS PRIVILEGED, WHITE,
STRAIGHT, CHRISTIAN MALE IN THIS
PRIMARY, THERE'S GOING TO BE
MOMENTS EITHER IN THE DEBATE OR
ON THE TRAIL WHERE HE IS GOING
TO GET ATTACKED AND HE IS GOING
TO SNAP AND HE'S GOING TO LOSE
BECAUSE HE IS FRUSTRATED AND
DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO HANDLE
HIMSELF.
THOSE WILL BE THE DEFINING
MOMENTS WHEN PEOPLE ATTACK HIM.
THE OTHER PROBLEM IS MEDIA,
BARACK OBAMA HAD 100% MEDIA
SUPPORT.
BIDEN IS NOT GOING TO HAVE THAT.
YOU'VE SEEN NOW,
"THE DAILY BEAST" WHICH IS A
TRADITIONAL PARTISAN ATTACK
RAGGED, THEY HAVE A STORY SAYING
OUT THIS WAS A BUMBLING AND
STUMBLING INTERVIEW.
HE NEEDS TO CONSOLIDATE MEDIA
SUPPORT BECAUSE RIGHT NOW HIS
OPPONENTS ARE DUMPING ALL THE
TRADITIONAL MEDIA PLACEMENTS,
THESE ONLINE PUBLICATIONS, THEY
DON'T LIKE HIM ANYWAY BECAUSE
HE'S TOO MODERATE AND CABLE NEWS
I BELIEVE EVERYBODY KNOWS ON
CABLE THAT JOE BIDEN IS AN
OVERRATED CANDIDATE THAN THEY
ARE GOING TO BUILD THEM UP AND
TEAR HIM DOWN AND YOU JUST
WATCH.
>> Dana: LET ME PLAY THIS FOR
YOU, TALK ABOUT WHAT JESSIE SAID
AND ALSO HOWARD DEAN'S POINT.
>> THIS PARTY HAS BEEN TAKEN
OVER BY 35-YEAR-OLDS, THE PEOPLE
WHO WON THE RACES ARE 35 YEARS
OLD AND THEY ARE MOSTLY
CENTRISTS.
THEY GET ALL THE PRESS.
THERE IS 37 PEOPLE THAT COME
FROM ORANGE COUNTY, TEXAS,
OKLAHOMA, KANSAS.
THAT'S WHERE WE PICKED UP THE
SEATS.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT THERE.
IT WAS LIKE HE WAS MAD THAT THEY
WERE YOUNG.
I JUST REALIZED, HE SCRAMBLED MY
BRAIN.
THE PROBLEM WITH JOE BIDEN IS
THAT HE'S BEEN AROUND FOR A
LONG, LONG TIME AND THERE IS NO
DEFINING POSITIVE ACHIEVEMENT HE
CAN .2.
HE IS LIKE THAT CHARACTER ON TV
SHOW THAT'S THERE ALL THE TIME,
GUNTHER ON FRIENDS, THE PARIS
STEP.
HE'S IN EVERY SINGLE EPISODE BUT
THERE'S NO IMPACT.
HE IS THE GUENTHER CANDIDATE, HE
IS LIKE YOUR TONSILS.
IF THEY'RE NOT THERE YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO MISS YOUR TONSILS,
DANA.
THIS IS A BATTLE BETWEEN
PHYSICAL EVIDENCE AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL EFFECT.
TRUMP OFFERS THE PHYSICAL
EVIDENCE OF ACHIEVEMENT, JOBS,
GREAT ECONOMY, GDP, STRONGER
MILITARY.
BIDEN OFFERS THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
STRATEGY.
TRUMP MAKES YOU FEEL BAD.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS IT WON'T WORK
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE TO LIKE
TRUMP TO VOTE FOR HIM, YOU
DON'T.
WE'VE GONE PAST THE IDEA OF
PERSONALITY AND WE ARE NOW
LOOKING AT THE PRACTICAL
ELEMENTS OF AN ADMINISTRATION
AND IT'S REALLY AN AWESOME TIME
IN HISTORY TO HAVE A PRESIDENT
WHO LIKES TO PARTICIPATE LIKE
AMERICA'S HECKLER.
YOU'RE JUST GOING TO GO ON FOR
TWO YEARS, TRUMP IS GOING TO BE
AMERICA'S HECKLER AND IT'S GOING
TO BE KIND OF FUN.
>> Dana: WE LISTEN TO ANOTHER
PIECE TO WHAT GREG WAS JUST
SAYING, JOE BIDEN ABOUT
AMERICANS COMING BACK.
>> AMERICA IS COMING BACK LIKE
WE USED TO BE.
ETHICAL, TELLING THE TRUTH,
MOVING IT AWAY.
ALL THOSE GOOD THINGS.
>> Dana: IS THAT THE RATIONALE
FOR HIS PRESIDENCY, THAT HE IS
GOING TO BRING US BACK TO ALL
THE THINGS WE JUST SAID, IS THAT
THE GOAL?
>> Juan: HE WANTS TO GET US
BACK AWAY FROM WHAT GEORGE
CONNOLLY HAS NOW CALLED
"DERANGED DONALD."
HE'S GOING TO BRING US BACK TO
CIVILITY, HONEST KINDS OF
CONVERSATIONS, NOT RACIAL
DIVISION, NOT BULLYING PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK YOU ARE
MISSING HERE, THE BIG NEWS OF
THE DAY IS JOE BIDEN RAISING
$6.3 MILLION IN 24 HOURS WHICH
WAY EXCEEDS MY EXPECTATIONS, I
DIDN'T THINK HE WAS CAPABLE OF
IT BECAUSE A LOT OF IT CAME FROM
SMALL DONORS WHO FUELED
BERNIE SANDERS AND I HAD THE
IMPRESSION THAT JOE BIDEN IS --
HAS NEVER BEEN A GREAT
FUND-RAISER, WOULD BE ABLE TO GO
AT IT IN THIS WAY.
HE DID.
DONALD TRUMP GOING AT HIM AS
SLEEPY OR TIRED OR DUMB, IT'S
JUST NOT TRUE.
HE IS INTELLIGENT -- LET ME
FINISH.
HE IS AN INTELLIGENT MAN.
I THINK MOST AMERICANS KNOW THAT
AND WHEN YOU SEE HIM ON "THE
VIEW" TODAY, HE'S TALKING ABOUT
HIS SON AND WHEN HE STARTS TO
CRY IN FRONT OF A MOSTLY FEMALE
AUDIENCE, HE COMES ACROSS AS
GENUINE, AUTHENTIC, CONNECTING
WITH WOMEN IN A WAY DONALD TRUMP
COULDN'T DREAM OF.
I KNOW JOE BIDEN, I'VE DEALT
WITH HIM.
JOE BIDEN WAS IN THE SENATE.
SIX TIMES SENT TO THE SENATE BY
THE CITIZENS OF DELAWARE, HE WAS
NOT ONLY THE GUY WHO WAS THERE
AHEAD OF JUDICIARY BUT FOR MANY
OTHERS BUT REMEMBER --
>> Greg: HE WAS GREAT WITH
ANITA HILL, YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT
THE WOMEN PART.
>> Juan: PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE, I KNOW IN YOUR
PARTISAN WORLD THAT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE, HE IS THE MOST ESTEEMED
SENATOR OF HIS TIME.
>> Dana: CAN I GET EMILY IN?
THE OTHER PEOPLE THAT INITIALLY
CAME OUT -- A LITTLE BIT OF A
BROADSIDE AGAINST BIDEN WAS
BERNIE SANDERS AND ELIZABETH
WARREN.
BERNIE SANDERS ATTACKING HIM FOR
HAVING A HIGH ROLLING
FUND-RAISER LAST NIGHT IN
PHILADELPHIA AND WAR -- IT WAS
KIND OF AN ARCANE ISSUE, SHE'S
NEVER REALLY LIKED HIM.
>> Emily: IT MAKES SENSE TO ME
THAT THEY CAME OUT SWINGING
RIGHT AWAY BECAUSE THEY ARE THE
ONES THAT HAVE THE MOST TO LOSE.
IF ANYONE THEY WILL LOSE THEIR
SUPPORTERS TO BIDEN.
AS THE ATTACKS INCREASE, I FEEL
LIKE IN TERMS OF THE PRESIDENT'S
ATTACK, AND TO SPEAK TO YOUR
POINT, EVERYBODY'S POINT, IT
MAKES ME THINK OF -- TRUMP IS
OUR SHARK IN THE WATER AND
REGARDLESS OF HOW MUCH MONEY
BIDEN RAISES HE IS SIMILAR TO A
JET IN THAT HE RAISED A TON OF
MONEY TO AND ULTIMATELY IT
DOESN'T MATTER AND TRUMP SMELLS
THAT GERIATRIC FIELD AND HE'S
GOING AFTER HIM BECAUSE IT'S
GOING TO BE EASY TO PICK OFF AND
HE WOULD LOVE TO RUN AGAINST HIM
IN 2020 BUT IT'S EASY TO PICK
OFF NOW.
HE IS 30 YEARS OF NOTHING AND I
THINK THE ARGUMENT OF NAME
RECOGNITION THERE'S ALSO A LOT
OF NAME FATIGUE AND YOU CAN SEE
IN THE MEDIA COVERAGE, THERE IS
SOME REPORTS THE MEDIA WAS
GLOWING REPORTS OF HIM AND "THE
VIEW" VIEWERS LOVE HIM.
I AM ON THE OTHER FLIP SIDE
WHERE THIS ENTIRE THING IS
TOTALLY LAUGHABLE.
>> Juan: WHAT I THOUGHT, I
THINK IT WORKED FOR HIM JUST
LIKE YESTERDAY WITH THE ROLLOUT,
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE SAID HEY,
WHY DID HE FOCUSED SO HEAVILY ON
CHARLOTTESVILLE?
TODAY, DONALD TRUMP IS BACK ON
WHAT HE SAID ABOUT
CHARLOTTESVILLE -- WOW.
>> Jesse: BIDEN QUOTED
THOMAS JEFFERSON, A SLAVEHOLDER.
>> Juan: ROBERT E. LEE WAS A